Due anni fa ho vissuto
la crisi più grande della mia vita non
ne ho mai parlato pubblicamente
e oggi ho deciso di farlo perché credo
che la mia storia
possa essere anche la vostra
questa storia inizia con un cuore
un cuore che batteva forte fortissimo
e che all'improvviso
si è spezzato
questo cuore batteva forte perché avevo
16 anni e stavo realizzando i miei sogni
avevo appena fatto un Ted sui problemi
adolescenziali che si è diffuso in tutta
Italia Stavo studiando con i più grandi
formatori internazionali stavo lavorando
con media Brand aziende giravo l'Italia
incontrando giovani di talento che mi
ispiravano ma soprattutto questo cuore
batteva fortissimo Perché io avevo
trovato la mia passione per la
comunicazione che mi faceva svegliare
ogni giorno pieno di energia non dormivo
la notte per fare quello che amavo non
vedevo l'ora di fare quello che amavo
ero felicissimo
e poi all'improvviso
il 17 novembre 2020
il vuoto
questo cuore
si spezza
avevo fatto un video sul tema della
didattica a distanza per un media Brand
seguito da milioni di persone che da
anni crea contenuti editoriali
divertenti per gli studenti
quel video diventa virale lo vede in
mezzo milione di persone ma fra questo
mezzo milione una sola
ha cambiato la mia vita
una giornalista molto conosciuta
influente di cui non farò il nome quel
giorno decide che non bastava attaccare
il contenuto del video si informa su
tutto quello che avevo realizzato negli
anni e decide di farmi finire in una
gogna mediatica troppo grande per un
adolescente troppo piccolo perché ha 16
anni non hai i mezzi per difenderti
ricevo insulti da tutta Italia sui
social
finisco sui giornali
perdo la stima di persone che
per me erano importanti in pochi secondi
di video
vedo distrutto tutto quello che avevo
realizzato in anni in pochi secondi di
video vedo completamente scomparire la
mia passione e proprio perché l'ho persa
dovevo fare di tutto per ritrovarla e
proprio perché ho sentito quel vuoto
dovevo fare di tutto per capire come
poter tornare ad essere appassionato e
proprio perché ho vissuto il periodo più
difficile della mia vita in questi due
anni sono diventato ossessionato
ossessionato dal tema della passione ho
studiato centinaia di ricerche
sull'argomento le ho raccontate in un
secondo Ted
e ho scritto un libro che è il primo
metodo scientifico per trovare quello
che amiamo
oggi voglio raccontarvi come potete
essere appassionati a ogni singolo
giorno della vostra vita ogni singolo
giorno della vostra vita qualsiasi cosa
facciate qualsiasi cosa facciate anche
le piccole cose anche le cose che non vi
piacciono quando siamo di fronte alla
nostra passione si attivano delle
particolari aree del cervello il circolo
chimico della passione è fatto di
sistema rettiliano dopamina e aree
prefrontali se queste aree non sono
attive scientificamente
non ci può essere passione Ma qui qui
arriva il bello perché noi esseri umani
abbiamo il grande potere grandissimo di
poter attivare queste aree in modo
autonomo quello che ho scoperto è che se
noi collaboriamo con il nostro cervello
attivando queste aree nel modo opportuno
Allora tutto tutto quanto può diventare
passione Anzi la vita stessa diventa
passione perché quando queste aree sono
attive il nostro cervello non distingue
quello che c'è davanti a noi per lui c'è
semplicemente passione senza genere
senza distinzione di genere e tipo non
distingue una passione per lo sport per
la musica
o per la cucina
partiamo dal sistema dopaminergico
controllato dal cervello rettile la
prima cosa che scatta nel nostro
cervello quando troviamo quello che ci
piace la nostra passione è la dopamina
neurotrasmettitore associato alla
ricompensa Al desiderio e agli stati
euforici normalmente
normalmente viene rilasciata in modo
naturale troviamo quello che ci piace
dopamina non dovete forzare niente ma
noi Noi siamo in grado di attivare la
dopamina in modo autonomo
come
avendo qualcosa da inseguire dandoci un
obiettivo un traguardo una meta qualcosa
da raggiungere qualcosa verso cui
tendere la cosa incredibile della
dopamina è che a differenza di altri
neurotrasmettitori del benessere che
vengono rilasciati dopo il
raggiungimento di un obiettivo la
dopamina viene rilasciata prima e
durante prima e durante l'inseguimento
dell'obiettivo stesso il neuroscienziati
lo definiscono Wanted Piacere
anticipatorio famosissimi sono gli
esperimenti di Wolfram Schulz il Wanted
è alla base della passione e c'è un
motivo evolutivo al wanting perché il
piacere anticipatorio della dopamina ci
ha permesso di sopravvivere
quando i nostri antenati Cacciatori
raccoglitorini etanolitica trovavano una
preda o un albero con i frutti nel loro
cervello iniziavano a registrarsi dei
picchi di dopamina e man mano che
avanzavano i picchi aumentavano sempre
di più sempre di più sempre di più
finché non raggiungevano la Scarica
finale quando raggiungevano l'obiettivo
funzionava così vedo l'obiettivo un
passo dopo Mina Un passo dopo Mina Un
passo dopo Mina finché non raggiungevano
l'obiettivo e avevano la Scarica finale
questo processo qui il wanting è stato
estremamente importante perché ha
consentito i nostri antenati di trovare
piacere nell'azione stessa nel
raggiungimento dell'obiettivo nella
caccia e questa ha consentito loro di
non accontentarsi del cibo che trovavano
immediatamente ma di procurarsi il cibo
per l'inevitabili momenti di scarsità
che sarebbero arrivati in futuro perché
grazie alla dopamina loro andavano a
caccia anche quando non erano spinti dal
bisogno della fame
dovete trovare qualcosa da inseguire
ogni giorno della vostra vita perché il
piacere della dopamina non è solamente
come spesso si pensa Quando io trovo
quello che voglio e arrivo all'obiettivo
Il piacere della dopamina è quando io
cammino e quando io avanzo è il viaggio
e l'avanzamento verso l'obiettivo la
passione quella vera non è la meta ma è
il viaggio è quello che scopro durante
il viaggio perché passione scoperta ed è
il desiderio di raggiungere quella meta
perché passione anche desiderio ma
soprattutto cosa più importante la
passione è la sensazione di sentirsi
Capaci
del ce la posso fare Sono in grado posso
arrivare lì una sensazione fondamentale
per una specie come la nostra che è nata
con pochissime competenze e una
possibilità di apprendimento infinito
noi esseri umani abbiamo il bisogno di
sentirci Capaci perché questa sensazione
che innesca il desiderio fondamentale
per la passione e la voglia di esplorare
fondamentale per la passione Questa è la
passione da un punto di vista chimico il
cervello non distingue se
quell'obiettivo è una tavola che dovete
disegnare un sito che dovete programmare
un piatto che dovete cucinare per il
cervello esiste solamente un obiettivo
qualsiasi
misurabile realizzabile tangibile
sfidante che voi siete in grado di
raggiungere sfidante perché se
L'obiettivo è impossibile
irraggiungibile oppure troppo scontato
troppo semplice la sensazione di
sentirsi Capaci non si attiva e quindi
nemmeno la dopamina il viaggio Il
cammino verso quell'obiettivo misurabile
tangibile realizzabile sfidante
diventerà passione
trovate qualcosa da inseguire e non solo
sarete appassionati ogni giorno ma
soprattutto è cosa più importante
saprete chi siete Vi faccio questa
domanda
chi siete
che cosa vi rende diversi da tutti gli
altri che cosa vi rende unici
io qui ho due fazzoletti
sono usciti Come avete visto esattamente
dallo stesso pacchetto hanno lo stesso
colore la stessa forma sono costituiti
dalla stessa percentuale di materia
Eppure Eppure nonostante questo non sono
gli stessi fazzoletti
che cosa li rende due fazzoletti diversi
spazio e tempo in un certo istante nel
tempo alle
11:16 di questo 24 gennaio questi due
fazzoletti occupano due spazi diversi
nella materia e questo li rende due
fazzoletti diverse con cui identità
diverse secondo il principio di
individuazione che afferma che ogni ente
ogni cosa è ciò che è e non è
qualcos'altro perché collocabile in una
certa posizione nello spazio in un certo
istante nel tempo noi esseri umani siamo
Esattamente esattamente come questi due
fazzoletti e abbiamo bisogno di avere
ben chiaro di avere ben chiaro lo spazio
che stiamo occupando
in un certo istante nel tempo perché se
non lo sappiamo non sappiamo Definire
chi siamo e se non sappiamo Definire chi
siamo siamo in crisi
Adesso vi faccio questa domanda
Dove siete
Qual è lo spazio che state
occupando sembra la domanda più
difficile astratta del mondo in realtà
la domanda più semplice e concreta del
mondo perché spazio e tempo Vivono di
punti di riferimento
indicatemi per favore con il braccio il
centro della stanza
indicatomi il centro della stanza
come fate a dirmi che quello è il centro
quel centro è il centro perché riceve il
senso riceve significato riceve valore
dal perimetro dalle pareti se voi sapete
Dove state andando se voi vi date un
punto di riferimento il vostro obiettivo
Allora in qualsiasi istante nel tempo
ogni giorno della vostra vita voi
saprete dire dove siete perché saprete
dire quanto vi manca Quanto distanti
siete da quell'obiettivo da quella meta
collocate un obiettivo nello spazio e
nel tempo
e collocherete anche voi stessi nello
spazio e nel tempo
e troverete chi siete
Io sono uscito dalla mia crisi quando ho
trovato qualcosa da inseguire che è
quello di aiutare ogni mese almeno una
persona almeno una persona a trovare
quello che ama obiettivo specifico da
quando inseguo Questo obiettivo io vedo
ogni mia azione come un passo in più ma
soprattutto ogni giorno io so definire
Chi sono Chi è Riccardo perché io so
benissimo che in questo preciso istante
nel tempo questa volta alle 11:19 di
questo 24 gennaio in questo preciso
posto sopra questo bollino rosso di
questo palco di questa aula magna di
questo liceo con questo discorso
Io ho fatto un passo in più
dopamina con gli interventi che farò
nelle scuole d'Italia nei prossimi mesi
Farò un altro passo in più
dopamina e io da quella crisi mi sento
vivo ogni singolo giorno perché sto
continuando a camminare
avere qualcosa da inseguire è il primo
punto fondamentale per essere
appassionati per rimanere appassionati
Mi dispiace
ma il sistema rettiliano Non basta la
dopamina non basta servono le aree per
frontali del cervello
le aree prefrontali del cervello
controllano il nostro impegno la nostra
attenzione la nostra capacità di
rimandare le gratificazioni Noi siamo in
una società che inibisce costantemente
la motivazione e il ruolo delle aree
prefrontali perché siamo costantemente
distratti dai Social E dai milioni di
stimoli che riceviamo ogni secondo è
questo il motivo per cui voi magari
trovate quello che vi piace ma
abbandonate subito È questo il motivo
per cui magari trovate quello che vi
piace ma cambiate subito perché vi
annoiate subito non è colpa vostra non
siete sbagliati dovete Allenare le aree
per affrontare ogni singolo giorno
perché altrimenti la struttura cerebrale
della motivazione si atrofizza E se
questo succede se le vostre aree
prefrontali sono deboli Mi dispiace per
voi Mi dispiace per voi e fa paura dirlo
ma rimanere appassionati nel lungo
periodo È scientificamente
impossibile
Come possiamo allenare le aree
prefrontali trovando qualcosa da fare
obbligatoriamente obbligatoriamente ogni
singolo giorno un obiettivo Piccolo
quotidiano può essere rifarsi il letto
ogni mattina meditare 10 minuti al
giorno leggersi tot pagine al giorno non
è importante cosa sia il punto
fondamentale è questo se non sei
costante nelle piccole cose allora non
avrai mai mai
la necessaria forza di volontà per fare
quelle grandi perché le tue aree
prefrontali non saranno abbastanza
allenate e quindi raggiungere
l'obiettivo
sarà impossibile
trovate qualcosa da inseguire Scegliete
con cura la vostra meta Scegliete con
cura anche i vostri compagni di viaggio
persone che credono in voi e che vi
ricordino costantemente che voi Ce la
potete fare che voi siete in grado che
vuoi lì ci potete arrivare diventate
costanti nelle piccole cose e tutto
tutto
Qualsiasi cosa può diventare passione
Magari sarà la vostra vera chiamata
magari no non importante perché in
entrambi i casi dovrete lavorare
duramente ogni giorno il problema della
passione così come dell'amore non è
innamorarsi il problema della passione e
dell'amore non è innamorarsi perché
innamorarsi È facilissimo il problema
dell'amore della passione è rimanere
innamorati
Questo è l'insegnamento più importante
che io ho imparato dalla mia crisi
rendete ogni cosa che fate
la vostra passione anche le cose piccole
che fate ogni giorno anche le cose che
non vi piacciono Perché scientificamente
possono diventare passione il nostro
cervello ci ha dato questa grande
grandissima possibilità e noi non
possiamo sprecarla se lo farete la
vostra vita diventerà passione io vi
auguro con tutto il mio cuore con tutto
il mio cuore di vivere sempre sempre
ogni giorno d'amore di passione cercate
costantemente quello che amate cercate
costantemente la vostra passione perché
la verità è che noi possiamo stare qui e
parlare di tutto quello che vogliamo e
possiamo discutere di tutto quello che
vogliamo ma la verità è che L'unica cosa
l'unica cosa che ci rende veramente vivi
ogni giorno
è questa
l'amore
[Applauso]
[Musica]